[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con un nuevo
estudio en la universidad de oxford
indica que las vacunas contra el cob y
19 de los laboratorios astrazéneca y
facer son efectivas contra la variante
delta detectada por primera vez en india
no obstante las autoridades sanitarias
del país asiático han identificado una
nueva mutación del coronavirus que se
llama ahora delta plus hasta el momento
se han reportado unos 40 casos y aunque
ya se sabe que es más contagiosa faltan
aún análisis para calificar la de más
peligrosa para conocer más del tema nos
acompaña el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
médico infectólogo de la universidad
nacional de colombia y asesor científico
de france 24 gracias por acompañarnos
más allá de los contagios identificados
qué datos se conocen hasta ahora de esta
nueva variante llamada delta plus que el
gobierno indio califica de preocupante
y marina está esta variante recordemos
que una variante son las las variaciones
y las mutaciones que tienen la proteína
espiga los virus hacen que tengan mayor
o menor adaptación hacia el ser humano
es decir que sea más efectiva la
transmisión la variante delta es muy
transmisible pero esta delta plus es
también más tiene mayor afinidad al
receptor que tenemos los humanos y hace
que sea mucho más efectivo de la
transmisibilidad incrementaría hasta un
90 por ciento de las capas es
transmisible humano y humano y esta
variante que ya ha sido reportada en al
menos 10 países como usted menciona
tiene algunas características distintas
hacen estas características que haya que
cambiar las medidas para evitar una
mayor expansión del virus o de la
variante en concreto
no definitivamente sabemos que el
distanciamiento físico y las medias de
higiene son la herramienta y la mejor
vacuna para evitar cualquier cualquier
estas variables y la vacunación efectiva
y masiva disminuye la posibilidad de
transmisión toda la falta de valorar si
son efectivas contra esta variante las
vacunas actuales probablemente sí lo sea
pero lo que es impresionante su
capacidad de transmisión que se puede
incrementar hasta un 90% en los grupos
humanos y precisamente usted hablaba de
que las vacunas hasta ahora sabemos que
si protegen de cierta manera contra las
variantes detectadas pero existe alguna
garantía de que los nuevos fármacos
también protejan contra estas nuevas
variantes que van surgiendo del virus
el problema es que no hay ninguna
certeza de cómo se pueden comportar
unas variantes y entre mayor número de
personas infectadas lo que estamos
viendo en américa latina con la variante
lambda o lo que estamos viendo en otros
grupos humanos que se incrementa la
transmisibilidad hay mayor posibilidad
de mutación y mayor posible de mutación
siempre es un riesgo para que las
vacunas no funcione por eso hay que es
vacunación y desaceleración de casos la
estrategia para erradicar la pandemia
y sabemos que estas variantes lo
llevamos diciendo estas semanas tienen
mayor capacidad de transmisión pero qué
pasa con las personas que ya han
superado el commit con una de las
variantes son inmunes o se pueden
contagiar de nuevo eso es lo que se está
evaluando en el momento la capacidad de
reinfección lo que hemos visto es que si
de efectivamente greene a hess distintos
pueden re infectar a las personas sin
embargo en pocas ocasiones se vuelve una
situación de europeo de importancia en
la salud pública pero estas variantes
tienen la capacidad de infectar
nuevamente a los seres humanos en esta
alerta plus estamos por evaluar esa
situación si fuera así pues toca
maximizar los esfuerzos para deshacer es
desacelerar el número de casos y sobre
todo la importancia de la vacunación
masiva y que sea simétrica no asimétrica
como lo que estamos viendo en nuestros
países actualmente marín y más allá de
esta preocupación de la que advierte el
gobierno indio donde se detectó esta
delta plus
son las medidas que hay que tomar
recordemos una vez más que al final el
virus lo podemos contener bastante
nosotros según como actuemos recuerde
nos cuáles son algunas de estas medidas
barreras que podemos que podemos llevar
a cabo es muy importante que todos
evitemos las aglomeraciones grandes
pequeñas son de la misma importancia si
hay humanos cerca si hay interacción
humana es la cadena de transmisión del
virus las medidas de higiene el uso de
tapabocas el lavado de manos la
vacunación cuando sea la oportunidad y
mantener una disciplina social es lo que
permite que estas variantes tengan menor
probabilidad que se desarrollen en la
medida que se incremente la vacunación
disciplina
es la clave higiene es la herramienta y
vacunación es la solución del problema
pues muchísimas gracias carlos eduardo
pérez como siempre nuestro asesor
científico en france24 hasta aquí cinco
minutos consigan con más en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]